here we go only on CBS this morning this
is my favorite story of the day we are
revealing the anonymous buyer behind
Olivia newton-john's Fame black satin
pants from Greece you know the ones look
at them they're here on set along with
one of the famous pink ladies jackets
because this anonymous buyer bought them
both yesterday we told you the pants
sold for more than one hundred and sixty
two thousand dollars at Julien's
Auctions in California special shout-out
by the way to the owner Darren Julian
Darren Julian who got these pants here
overnight thank you very much Darren
Julian from California some of the
auctions proceeds will go to
newton-john's cancer and Wellness Center
that's in Australia the skin tight pants
became an instant icon when she wore
them during the song you're the one that
I watch during a recent interview for
CBS Sunday morning we asked her to try
them on again how many people think
Olivia can get the pants that's amazing
that's amazing how many people can get
advanced that they were 40 years ago
I'll go first
now and the pants live again right now
only on CBS this morning
we are happy to reveal that drum roll
please Blakely [ __ ] the pan oh my god
jacket presented to Olivia newton-john
by the movies cast and crew sera sera
sera thank you for translations I got
the I got the pants how did this come
about when did you decide you were gonna
go for it and why well listen I have
been the biggest fan of Olivia since I
was a little girl since Greece came out
and my friend called me two days before
the auction I didn't know it was
happening and she said Sarah Olivia you
know they're putting the pants up and
the outfit for charity and I thought oh
my god I've got to try to get so we went
a little above the estimate yeah why
would I get yourself and did you have a
game plan good
I had never what I had no game plan I
was actually here in New York for my
anniversary with my husband we were out
to dinner and I had a friend bidding for
me so she was on speakerphone while we
were at dinner but listen this is what I
said I go honey honey I won the pants
he's like let's be clear you didn't win
you paid the most dollar question what
do you do with them okay what I do with
them is Spanx I'm gonna frame them and
hang them at Spanx because we have black
faux leather leggings that it becomes
dude you got some on right now you'd be
very they're very oh they have become a
cult following and they're inspired off
of Olivia's pants so you know she's the
og of black leggings I had to own a mess
yes and I'm also just a huge fan of hers
and it was Finnerty saying at your
wedding how is that okay for you guys
friends know so I don't know Olivia but
but I had this dream I got married yeah
that's at my wedding
that's it okay so that's where I'm
telling Jesse I go honey that's Olivia
knew John he thought that it was the
wedding singer I surprised not only my
husband but every single person at the
wedding my mom didn't know no one in the
wedding party knew and I called somebody
who knew her and I just said this would
be a dream of mine and so my husband and
eyes first damn what a song it was using
hopelessly devoted so so our first
wedding song was a compilation of four
songs because I knew my husband wouldn't
go for just hopelessly devoted as our
first dance song so he got to choose two
songs I chose two we took 15 seconds of
each song and I made sure we ended our
first dance song with the hope oh it is
oh nice so she so it's the music's just
playing hopelessly devoted and right at
the moment where it goes but now the
music stopped she walked out and saying
everybody was crying I didn't know so we
reached out to Olivia let's see what
Olivia had to say oh my goodness Gail I
just heard the news of who brought my
jacket and pants and I'm so incredibly
excited that it went to this person
because I happen to have sung at her
wedding and I still have the cards that
she gave out as party favors I'm so
delighted Sarah that you have my pants
and jacket I couldn't think of anybody
better to have them because they're the
original Spanx right those are hats so
thank you so much you've done so much of
my hospital I'm totally grateful to you
thank you so much I've been dancing to
her since I was 7 years old I mean the
eight-track of Greece are you kidding me
was always playing in my house that's
yeah I mean we'll listen there I am but
I tell you guys there's an 8 year old
little girl from Clara Beach Florida who
is flipping out right now that I own
these pants this is an American Dream
moment Sarah you should have these fancy
yes no question thank you I know Jesse
says you paid for but I really do think
you want I can't wait to see them on
display at your headquarters that's
great yes Congrats thank you thank you
thank you for very absolute ly Bri
slating I was expecting to do do a duet
Gail was game